oh boy how do we do this okay
is this weird or helpful that question
should be asked of so many things right
now
[Music]
oh no
my name is grace helbig if you did not
know now you know your life is different
now welcome to this video hmm
we haven't done this in a second yeah i
uh
one word at a time make sentences which
form thoughts
i'll avoid it by touching my hair so i
wanted to make a video that wasn't
a cooking video i've taken a little bit
of a
step back i've created some boundaries
and some space between myself
and youtube and talking
in videos like this and so i thought
it's about time
just give an update to provide you a few
minutes of a safe space and which i
won't
try to impose i can't say that for sure
i can't say that
i just want to give you some updates and
to talk to you about some things
great vague i sound like a trump doctor
i'm nervous to talk to you because we
haven't talked in a while
and i've been following the rules of
quarantine and i haven't uh my ability
to have conversations
with people uh before all of this was
a little difficult think it's gotten
i went on my instagram story last week
or two weeks
ago and asked you guys to ask some
questions about things you were curious
about
and i've collected a bunch of them and
i'm going to answer them for you i drank
a lot of
caffeine to get me amped for this and
sometimes
all the time things in excess are not
good how are you doing first of all
which is a loaded question and i don't
even know if that's safe to ask because
we're all [ __ ]
experiencing trauma in so many different
angles and directions
i hope you're doing okay and i hope like
me
you're taking time to really think about
things naps
and masks are where it's at don't forget
to breathe have you been able to see
your brothers or parents
in this quarantine for the most part
i've seen my family over zoom my
stepbrother lives out here in los
angeles i got to see him
but everyone else is on the east coast
and so everything's been
virtual if anything the positive side of
this is that my mom has gotten
a lot better at her use of gyps on my
birthday
she just sent me a ton of gifts of uh
angels who told me this is how you came
into the world
so she's she's doing great how is grad
school going
okay this is the big news that if you
guys don't listen to this might get
weird the podcast i do with my heart on
a weekly basis it comes out every
wednesday and you can watch full
episodes onto this might get youtube
channel if you don't listen to that then
you probably don't know because i
haven't said it anywhere else
because it is kind of a personal thing
but it's a major thing
i'm back in school i started a master's
program i'm studying
uh deaf psychology jungian psychology
and it's an engaged humanities program
that sounds a little weird or vague
and to be honest i don't exactly know
what my plan is
with this degree but i do know that
i'm in a major transitional part of my
life and that i
really really craved structure and i
wasn't able to provide that for myself
a very liberating thing to realize when
you need to outsource to be able
to work on your inner source so i've
been busy with that for the last
month and it's been very cool to go back
to school and it also adds to my brain
being
flooded and overwhelmed in a wonderful
way i'm very very
interested in this side of psychology
with technology
and with the way that like we're
watching in real time
how you know it's affecting all of us
that have been
working and living and identifying with
this system affects our mental state i'm
eager to share with you guys
everything i'm learning but i feel like
i'm in the mode where i just have to
like
absorb and process everything that i'm
learning and then filter it through
a lens that makes sense that i'm
passionate about
and be able to create from there
[Applause]
that's kind of weird vague fluffy
creative arty wufoo kind of talk
that's where i'm at i've said before in
videos that i've had a really difficult
time feeling like this roller coaster
ride of youtube
was going up up up up up up and then
kind of like
stalled i was really enmeshing myself in
my identity of creating things online i
was having a really difficult time with
that this quarantine really shifted
a lot of things into a different
perspective i just want to go back to
school to learn these
tools that i think could be really
valuable in helping people in the future
like i said tech [ __ ] is weird the
social dilemma did you watch it
a devil device also social media it has
been helpful
and really detrimental it's affecting
people's brains
and their personalities the way that
they evolve and grow
and i don't think it's doing really good
things for
people i just feel like now's the time
for me to learn more why we do what we
do and how we do what we do and then
maybe potentially eventually be able to
figure out
some stuff that could be helpful this is
just words noise
i'm very excited i've been doing youtube
videos for a decade
and the well has far far past run dry
it's just a dusty bat cave but i think
it could get moist again
i got lots of stuff stewing in my brain
and i'm really excited and maybe as i go
along i'll
explain more stuff to you or maybe i'll
get really nervous and anxious about it
and i'll keep it to myself and let it
just sort of fester for a little bit now
you know that i'm back in school in a
master's program and i'm really excited
about it
and also reading's hard and i forgot
about that i'm such a little baby [ __ ]
when it comes to reading and i got to
read a lot of things so
that's where i'm spending a lot of my
time i feel like oh
how big you made a adult decision
and look at okay 35. here we go you can
still wear shirts that say [ __ ] with the
rose but we could also
go back and get our masters how do you
deal with the continually shifting
landscape of youtube read your career
that's kind of the major question i was
facing all this year and last year
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do and i think
i'm not alone
in that panicky paralyzing kind of place
i've always felt a little bit like an
outsider on youtube like i've never
known
how to take advantage of the algorithm
i've never really cared about like
creating a focused business strategy
about growing an audience or growing a
brand or
[ __ ] the people that do a really
wonderful at it and kudos to them but
for some reason i could never get myself
to really like consistently do that
know that all my taglines are like
consistently inconsistent and i don't
know i've been screaming at the world
i'm not
the sophisticated business brain that
can figure this system out
and and work it for all it's worth and
youtube is a very strange place now
feels very foreign to me which is
probably why
i'm so nervous even sitting down and
doing this everything that i've been
doing this year has like
separated me from this so doing this
sitting down which used to be so
familiar and normal feels very foreign i
think i'm growing i think my whole kind
of lens is like
shifting also i'm curious what do you
guys think about youtube
right now i mean you've also been in it
for years and years and years i don't
find myself watching youtube videos
anymore like i used to i mean i watched
a video
to fix my refrigerator the other day
it's become more of a tool
and a source of entertainment what's
your experience on youtube now
how do you use it what are you watching
is it enjoyable
etc etc etc i just quit my job of six
years to go back to college hahaha i'm
so scared how do i adult
hey it's very trendy right now
apparently to make a big life pivot
especially
when it's oriented towards school
whether you're trying or not you're
doing adult so congratulations it's just
you're on the ride you're going you
don't need to push a button to start
it has begun but just enjoy the ride
you know that easy not difficult thing
to do
i would say take a second to
congratulate yourself for making a big
change that's huge and obviously super
important to you fear is good
i'm terrified of the things that i've
been doing
but i have to understand that fear
is just excitement and a tacky outfit
but recognizing that you're scared it's
good because if you try and push the
fear away and pretend it's not there
bad stuff can happen i'm on my period
and i'm a sad and crampy emotional [ __ ]
will i get better
no a period is like having emotional gas
which you do have during your period
literally but metaphorically it's
uncomfortable but it just moves through
you and it finally gets out and you're
good for a little bit until you eat way
too much cheese again what's your
preferred kind method type strain
what have you of weed i haven't been
drinking for a few months
and instead i've been hanging out with a
dear friend
marijuana i realized that drinking when
you're in a really kind of
stressful and unsure emotional state
does not help in any way i mean do
people know about that i feel like
people should really know about that
when you're lost
oh liquor does not give you the correct
directions they're like an uber driver
that takes the wrong turn and refuses to
let you know
you're like where are you going it's
like no i got you we're going we're
moving right but i don't think this is
right now now
i should have been home like 15 minutes
ago but this is pretty fun
look i can go this way and go this way
we can go into the ocean if we want to i
don't think that's right so that said i
have been smoking more but i prefer
to drink marijuana i love canned
cannabis quencher
concentrates that you can mix in with
like
seltzers or sodas so you can like make a
weed cocktail that's become
like my favorite thing to do at the end
of the night who knew
i definitely didn't also and i just have
like trash taste so i haven't like taken
time to develop like
what strand i like more than other
strands i'm just like we gimme nom nom
nom that's what i'm at if you have any
recommendations for stuff that you
prefer that makes you
creative and relaxed and fun please
by all means give me some
recommendations how are the plants in
the toilet doing
knew the most successful thing in my
life this year would be a toilet well
that's the only thing that actually does
make sense can you write another book
i can i have my brain can form sentences
and i do have a laptop so technically i
can write another book
i think i'm getting some really
wonderful information
via school stuff and i'm just starting
this new learning journey
so i think a book will come out of this
process that i'm really excited
to potentially eventually do how's goose
how you doing
yeah cool what advice do you have for a
26 year old still living with
parents separate yourself from any shame
that you're feeling about that
everything's been turned upside down
this year give yourself credit and be
gentle we're all trying to handle and
figure out
how to exist to our best abilities in
this situation
i don't know your relationship with your
parents but like pranking your parents
as an adult while you're at home
sounds like a pretty cool opportunity
for a great hobby
good luck left any vibrators in hotels
recently no
i have not been to a hotel since
february so
there hasn't really been an opportunity
to lose my cooter companion
so but i'll keep you posted why is joe
biden the only viable option in the
presidential election just go
off sis i don't think it serves us at
all anymore to be
pissed off that joe biden is the option
i think we have to move
towards something better than what the
[ __ ] is happening now we
have to have to have to support the good
that is available i mean this in the
most loving way possible
get the [ __ ] over it and get out and
vote this year do you ever long for the
days of youtube in 2014
yes and no i long for the sweetness of
the
sense of discovery about what the
they're all doing there's a sense of
innocence there's a lot of cringe back
there there's a lot of nostalgia and i
think i got caught up a lot and wanting
to just
live in 2014 and you can't do that you
gotta grow and change
yeah this is such a mature video i don't
i'm uncomfortable with it are you
drinking enough water
clearly not absolutely not thank you
mom for reminding me and for all of you
go drink some water something you can
have with your water
yeah our vitamins i don't do a ton of
brand deals
anymore because i only do brand deals
with the products that i actually
use i finally got a refill on my care of
because i go through these vitamins
so quickly i don't have many routines
but taking these first thing in the
morning
is pretty much my only consistent
routine but they're sponsoring today's
video so let me tell you a little bit
about care of
if you are interested because they make
taking vitamins something that we're all
told to do but i don't know
if you're like me and you just don't do
it uh they make it way easier so the
products are obviously good for you but
they use clean
ingredients that are backed by science
and they're super transparent about the
research that they use
that goes into all of the vitamins and
supplements that they offer
just take their quiz it takes like five
minutes to ask you questions about your
diet
your lifestyle like what are your
wellness concerns so they can help
narrow down
items that might be more relevant to you
and then based on your answers they give
you
the expert recommendations and you can
take those recommendations or you can
customize
your vitamin kits at any time and then
when you decide on what you want they
send you your little custom box with
your custom vitamin kits with your name
on them there's my name
and if you are interested in care of you
can get 50 off your first order 5-0
half off your first order by going to
take care of dot com
and using the offer code wow again
fifty percent off first order take care
of that prom offer code
wow well there you go guys i hope this
video was
interesting or helpful or at least
entertaining in some capacity there's
not so many jokes flying around but
that's because my brain is a little bit
fried you guys haven't seen much of me
lately because i've been busy becoming
an adult oh if you like this video let
me know because i
would like in the future to sit down and
do some more of these with you
give me a thumbs up give me a thumbs up
or subscribe to this youtube channel
who knows when videos will be up and
isn't that part of the
fun and frustration other than that
i don't know